converse here author of the 4-hour
workweek for our body for our chef tools
Titans and so on and so forth I talk a
lot about stoic philosophy they've had a
lot of questions about stoic philosophy
I produced audio books about stoic
philosophy which have made their way
into Super Bowl teams all the way from
management to players and everything in
between
why do I talk about stoic philosophies
so much well to a lot of people who are
watching this and as was true for me for
a very long time you hear stoic and you
think maybe of a cow standing in the
rain just accepting whatever tragedy and
terrible circumstances befall it that is
not what I'm advocating at all or maybe
you imagine somebody with no emotion
whatsoever also not what I'm advocating
so the way we use stoic and modern
English is is somewhat different from
the way that it was used when it came
from stoah which is actually porch and
specifically I think that stoicism is a
fantastic operating system for thriving
in high stress environments what does
that mean it means that it is a
framework for making better decisions
and training yourself to be less
reactive it goes very well with
different types of meditation whether
that's TM or using an app like headspace
for calm so on but you don't necessarily
need both they're complimentary stoic
philosophy and I should say that
probably around 2004 I picked up a book
that was the collected letters of Seneca
Seneca the younger who's one of the real
figure heads I would say in the last few
years at least who has become very
popular as a stoic thinker and writer
has been popular for some thousand plus
years but there's been a huge resurgence
others would include Marcus Aurelius
used to be the Emperor of Rome the most
powerful man in the world of time and
then there are others Cato and so on
Epictetus
who was formerly slave so you have a
very wide spectrum of well-known stoic
fingers and you should find the one that
speaks to you best but I picked up this
book of Senecas writing didn't really
expect much of it
and when people ask me now what is your
favorite book of all time the book
you've read the most the book you gifted
the most I've gifted hundreds of copies
of Senecas letters so the morale letters
to Luke Ilyas Luc ili us the morale
letters to Achilles by Seneca the
younger he was very famous playwright
one of the wealthiest people in Rome
advisor to the Emperor that ultimately
didn't work out so well for him but he
was on the front line so what I
appreciate about stoic philosophy is how
well it is used in highly challenging
circumstances and the some of the basics
of stoic philosophy which have been
applied in Super Bowl which had been
applied in training of all different
types have been applied by prisoners of
war POWs in wartime like Stockdale for
instance James Stockdale or I would say
a few things number one it trains you
much like the serenity prayer in a way
but it's more systematic to focus on
differentiating between things that you
can control and things you cannot
control and really only focusing your
energy on the former so for instance if
you watch your friends spinning out of
control on social media freaking out
about politics and all they do is [ __ ]
and whine and whinge about politics well
if we sat down and thought about it the
vast majority of those people are not
going to be in a position normally and
take steps to change any of that reality
therefore is a lot of wasted energy and
calories and brain cycles right so
really really learning to repent it and
repetitively consistently focus on
things that are within your sphere of
control that doesn't mean that you are
passive and certainly the reason that
people like Thomas Jefferson George
Washington the founders of this great
country of the United States of America
were certainly rebels and
revolutionaries and extremely aggressive
and contrarian in many many ways
went to stoicism is because they knew
they had a lot of hard battles ahead and
they wanted to
make wise decisions right so number one
you're learning to focus on and expand
the sphere of action that you have the
things you can control
next you're going to systematically
train yourself to be less prone to
overreacting to say criticism so kato
who is considered by some to be the
perfect stoic fascinating character see
ato would sometimes wear a tunic of an
unpopular color so that he would be
ridiculed in the senate and by other
people he did this specifically and
other things like it so that he would
train himself to only be ashamed of
those things worth being ashamed of so
the superficial things he would
experiment with and he would catalyze
other people making fun of him or
insulting him so that he would develop a
tolerance for it this is very very
practical and there are many corollaries
to this as well as the next piece which
is in effect practicing poverty and the
worst case scenario so that they hold
less power over you and that can take
the form of say Kevin Kelly who's been
on the Tim Ferriss know podcast
fascinating technology futurist as well
as founding editor of Wired magazine so
he knows worst case scenario because he
has done so much backpacking and lived
off of instant oatmeal the worst case
scenario he can always have his backpack
instant oatmeal and a cup of coffee and
he can be happy and he knows that
because he's practiced it and Seneca in
letter 13 of his letters to kill Lewis
the moral literacy Lucilius which was I
believe on festivals and fasting talks
about setting aside a certain number of
days and then paraphrasing here but a
certain number of days during which you
will eat the cheapest affair where the
coarsest of dress etc asking yourself
all the while is this the condition that
I so feared so practically speaking I've
built this into my own life by fasting
by exposing myself to cold I have a
practice of cold exposure which is done
very safely I have different types of
plan suffering
and planned poverty's so that any type
of unplanned suffering or unplanned
financial hit will have less of an
impact on me and this applies in many
different fields this is I suppose a
compatible ethos with the more you sweat
and peacetime the less you bleed in
wartime alright you want to prepare for
the unexpected turns of fate by
simulating what the worst-case scenarios
would be this is very very practical and
if we look back to Cato for instance
while he would wear these ridiculous
outfits you know I will spend time
walking through say California in San
Francisco okay hippie liberal central
with a cowboy hat on just to see what
happens because you will get all sorts
of sideways glances and so on and I
might then go to Utah I went to a very
conservative part of Utah and I wore
what I call my party pants for a day or
two and party pants are these very
flamboyant bright blue floral patterned
pants from bonobos I don't really sell
them anymore which effectually looked
like the upholstery on your grandma's
couch they are hideous and did that very
deliberately to force me to interact
with people in a way that would
condition me to be able to take bolder
steps or have more uncomfortable
conversations in the future because all
serious problems all important matters
require uncomfortable conversations I
think you can measure your success in
many ways by the number of uncomfortable
conversations you're willing to have and
stoicism helps with that so I go down
the list but there are very very
practical steps to take and then you can
translate that into your own life so for
instance a lot of the advice that you
might get from a former Navy SEAL
commander like Jocko willing he wouldn't
call stoicism but the mental toughness
that he has developed and also trained
in other people is very much not going
to say identical but a close cousin to
stoicism and if if you look at for
instance advice that you would get once
your
rust into the public eye and a lot of
these letters the Morel understood gills
are long lines of dear Lukey Lewis I
hear you're being slandered by your
so-called friends so-and-so in the
Senate and he did this but then he said
this behind your back here's how I would
recommend that you deal with the
situation and I would translate that
into for instance advice that I give
people who are about to get a lot of
public exposure and I say you never as
bad as they say you are and you're never
as good as they say or all right and I
want to touch on a common misconception
or maybe aspect of stoicism people find
unattractive so you never as bad as they
say are you're also never as good as
they say you are and this helps you to
keep a level head some people fear that
if they if they adopt stoicism or study
so sysm that they will become this very
Vulcan like creature that has neither
this certainly has has less of a dip in
terms of the lows of life but that's
simultaneously you're going to sacrifice
the highs you won't have the peaks of
joy that you experience as a normal
person if you focus on stoicism to that
I would say number one you are a
thinking person and much like any book
you would read you can pick and choose
so you can pick and choose the elements
that you find most useful you think are
going to be most applicable to you and
then you can test them all right so I
happen to think of my own philosophies
not as stoicism and not as a as an
evangelist necessarily for stoicism to
proselytize other people I pull from
elements of say Buddhism resent Buddhism
I also pull elements from
epicureanism which was really seen as
almost the opposite of stoicism but to
be maximally content and to find joy in
the small things I find that to be a
very helpful counterbalance to some of
the stove's looking which can get a
little dry in somber at times but what
stoicism will do if you embrace it in
many respects and Zen Buddhism also very
helpful for this is helping to develop a
present state awareness so that you are
aware of your thoughts and emotions
before they take control of you
need you to make very bad decisions
whether that's lashing out at someone
verbally whether that is making an
impulse buy or sell decision or
otherwise it is a fantastic insurance
policy that allows you to have more
consistent well-being throughout your
life in all areas and that to me rather
than a cow standing in the rain a
stoicism and certainly I view it as one
of the keys to any success that I have
had in the last decade or more whether
that is in the world publishing
podcasting angel investing or otherwise
I really think that this is a core
underlying foundation upon which my best
decisions have been built so I hope the
same for you and PS I feel so strongly
about the value of this and I want to
thank everyone it is listen to my
podcast or read anything I've written
that I've put together three volumes of
stoic writing primarily Seneca and I'm
giving them away for free so I'm giving
away as ebooks it's called the Tao of
Seneca ta o the Tao of Seneca and there
are gorgeous original illustrations that
I had commissioned there is incredible
calligraphy from both Japanese and
Chinese masters so I want to show some
of the parallels between philosophical
schools that are dropped into this and
it features I want to say at least 120
letters from Seneca to Luke Elias so you
can find those for free and I really
hope that you find value in them and
share them with other people but that's
the town of Seneca and you can go out
and find it at your leisure
so that for now is everything that I
want to share on stoicism but it's taken
me very very far and I hope and expect
the same for all of you hope you enjoyed
the video if you would like to see my
favorite piece of content that I put out
every week it is a short newsletter five
bullet Friday it's free five bullet
points with the coolest things that I've
been finding using testing in a given
week I put it out every Friday you can
digest it
five minutes take a look Bible of Friday